[Musica]
[Applauso]
e morto nel 2000
people in the world quasi 6 miliardi
maggio dove sono nella london
international avevamo 1,4 miliardi di
hardware internazionali la domanda è
qual è la percentuale della popolazione
mondiale che è effettivamente viaggiato
all'estero quell'anno per piacere
il 3 per cento per dirla in parole
semplici sono sempre le stesse persone
che viaggiano ancora a battisti ho
sentito di questi dati statistici quasi
un mese fa in una conferenza di turismo
ad atene e devo ammettere che sebbene
fossi nel settore da apparecchiata
quindi quando ho saputo che di essere
oggi qui fra sentivo che dovevo
condividere questo per due motivi del
bis conception dal people dei modi tutor
li volevo affrontare l'idea sbagliata
cui molti di noi spendiamo il nostro
tempo e denaro per viaggi di piacere
internazionali a ogni d'età cancro se
poi section shift in secondo luogo
volevo mostrarvi come i nuovi daina
possono causare un cambiamento di
percezione e quando dico questo poi
all'inizio quando vi ho dato alla prima
parte dei dati aver aggiornato i
macchinari che pensato guado ci sono
molti viaggi ma subito dopo quando avete
sentire la risposta va tutto è cambiato
e avete pensato
aspettiamo milito non ci sono molte
persone che viaggiano davvero a les
murray linea penn su interpreti the same
d'età in quello che realmente è successo
allora speck che avete interpretato per
gli stessi fatti sotto una prospettiva
totalmente diverso e black campo e se
pensiamo a questo semplice esempio
abbiamo fatto
ed è esattamente questo che fa il
viaggio ci dà il potere di cambiare il
muro vediamo le cose tra valente raidue
c'è solamente una condizione viaggiare
molto giovane di drag queen a wish e
cosa intendo dire con questo tenero con
voi nei prossi 1t ma prima ci facciamo
una piccola parentesi novembre studenti
trentini i tempi a novembre 2003 si sono
le dieci di sera
nel mio salotto come sapete in mezzo in
un lungo periodo di recessione e io sono
appena tornato a casa costa per le
misure come tra sono lì seduto di
pensieri di picasso dalla mia testa e
nei call my parents allora prende il
telefono e chiama i miei genitori e la
mia madre ha risposto e dico un uomo
baba l'estero e le ha detto ma questo è
fantastico ma dove stai andando a moving
a movie koreja e io gli ho detto mamma
no non per una vacanza da io mi
trasferirò strali e allora il silenzio
sono sicuro abbastanza che ha voluto che
abbia sentito parlare del fenomeno
mondiale chiamato la madre greca si dice
in giro che può essere un po
iperprotettiva 5 b non è la mia madre ma
lo potrebbe essere a dir la verità però
questa la mezza quando le cose non vanno
bene può essere veramente veramente
arrabbiata dopo aver riagganciato e
mission to mi sono reso conto che
trasferirsi all'estero sarebbe stato
come
avesse inizio a riunirsi missione su
marte
aveva allora riconsiderare le mie
opzioni so dove va all'estero o doveva
portarmi ai the last ero a casa
experience company english e ho fatto
appunto questo ho creato una compagnia
di esperienze di viaggio in grecia
da quel momento il mio obiettivo ormai
sedimentato quello di progettare viaggi
per i viaggiatori per a rimane in grecia
non mater destination del pippo per cui
trovo però subito ho pensato perché
alcuni viaggi sono molto migliori viatri
l'india evidentemente dalla destinazione
o dalle persone che uno i quali
viaggiamo quali sono i fattori la tess
per rendere un viaggio fantastico aver
trascorso molti anni viaggiando e
creando viaggi per oltre 10mila
viaggiatori in grecia
ho realizzato che esistono tre
ingredienti necessari per una ricetta di
successo
la prima cosa che conta davvero è
viaggiare responsabilmente at the time
to study da customs off
prendetevi di tempo di studiare le
abitudini del paese visitando ai
rispecchi glocal calcio non solo skull
queste rete della conoscenza di scrivere
la canzone locale e impossibili chi più
europeo e non solamente renderà
l'esperienza più autentica
ma forse magari destinati anche fuori di
prigione
by from locali shops and poor dell'oca
fco durante il vostro viaggio comprate e
no tre negozi e mangiate dove la gente
del posto mangia e due i make your
wallet la fa più non so se n'è detto
sono avviate l'economia locale ma anche
il vostro portafogli sarà molto più
felice ravalli 2 country morgan in
e custom è un altro amico la cosa con
due sì a meno che se non paesi dove la
contrattazione del prezzo è un'abitudine
tutto questo non fatelo cambiare il mio
euro per noi non cambia niente ma può
significare moltissimo per la persona
che abbiamo davanti fuori lei può essere
un pasto intero e prima di partire
assicurato di essere accordati per
quello che siete e non per quello che vi
siete lasciati alle spalle dei turisti è
la gestione diventa un gravissimo
problema per le popolare oltre il quale
per cento di tutti i rifiuti hanno da
turisti
dobbiamo minimizzare è molto semplice
riutilizzabile una borsa 18 invece di
quella di plastica bing e creative per i
tax al match più bello bel vantaggio mi
maggiore bene più grande è quello che ci
fa sentire molto meglio viaggiare senza
responsabile trova l'experience e di
soddisfare i sensi routing le esperienze
sono un enorme ravaldino tex italia per
l'aumento degli sponsor to the
increasing demand dai fashion era la
risposta del caso stati public marmor
ala millenial tendenza dei lycans di
viaggiare sempre di più week l'opening
farm and one the biggest retail store da
huxley on any items dacia mason iii
millennio globi sono cresciuti in un
fenomeno è in una società tanto il più
grande negozio al mondo non possiede
articolo
grande compagnia di strevi traguardo non
possedere i coli at least bus
sebbene siamo cresciuti allora di
abbondanza almeno nella parte maggiore
del mare occidentale patria
siamo arrivati a risorse per questo che
le nostre esperienze sono una parte più
grande di noi delle cose materiali al
tifo ed è esattamente questo millennio
che stiamo cercando fra voi quando
viaggiamo perché millennio ac al iv non
stanno viaggiando per divertirsi
solamente solo viaggiando fronde
millennio per ritrovare all'interno del
mondo chase the way we all presto allora
che è iniziato dai millennio cioè
diventato un fenomeno generatore davvero
aveva avviato in un modo di viaggiare e
stu invest on experiences and
dimostrando a tutti che la cosa migliore
che possiamo fare è investire in
esperienze e ogni volta con tranche
abbiamo facciamo un passo superiore al
pass investiamo investiamo in esperienze
di trasformazione e ciò che ci aiuta a
diventare una versione migliore di se
stessi a charlie ma if it was homeless
che niente di quello che io ho già detto
non fare nulla se non ci sono le
reazioni umane is all about connecting i
viaggi sono tutti per le connessioni wan
ai advise intrapreso na li il triplo act
e quello che vi consigliano da fare sky
sarebbe stata la prova tv o e non ha
iniziato una discussione con il casinò
locale o un vecchietto che arrivano in
villaggio lontana discussion i'm into
you go beyond superfici al communication
io vi dico di no e tess cominciare una
discussione e cerco di arrivare oltre
alla comunicazione superficiale a cui
siamo abituati action is here
sgomberate le totale di tv lie talmente
più facile apprensione persona estranea
trovate le vedrete su web connecting
with l'igiene quando abbiamo questa
connessione guadagniamo veramente tanto
i trilli e life changing experience to
meet and young boys ultra valls fifteen
kilometres già state fisco è
un'esperienza che cambia la vita di
incorporare un ragazzo che cammina
francis chilometri al giorno
solamente per la gioia della sua scuola
cir e allegramente per ciò che diamo per
scontate in india è un'esperienza che ci
capita rendersi conto che se importa se
arriviamo in giappone o in italia o in
india
tutti abbiamo le stesse agonie le stesse
paure le stesse speranze gli stessi
sogni clavo does not start il viaggio
nel quale arriviamo nel paese
d'estrazione compariamo i biglietti da
boeing upload praxis il viaggio inizia
nel primo momento in cui il pensiero di
andare all'estero ci colpisce
se avessi allora solamente tre desiderio
questi sarebbero fra valmor viaggiare di
più fra valid right way viaggiare nel
modo giusto volpato nice to the same e
fare aiutare gli altri a fare come
quello successivo e vi aiuterà ad
evolvere e better place ea rendere il
nostro mondo un posto migliore grazie
[Applauso]